faccio un tuffo sotto il sole
fa già un caldo che si muore
quest'estate non si dorme
me la bevo come un cocktail
ho voglia di andare più forte
non ci basterà questa notte
voglio vedere le luci dell'alba cambiare colore
voglio ballare con te
soltanto con te
non chiedo la luna ma un ballo con te
lasciamoci tutto alle spalle io e te
fino a che nasce il sole
come il crimine
senza regole
come le ragazze con il grilletto facile
entriamo senza pagare
come dei calciatori di serie A
ci guarda tutto il locale
ma alla fine nessuno ci toccherà
Quiero ver bailar tu pelo
Quiero ser tu ritmo
Que le enseñes a mi boca
Tus lugares favoritos
Déjame sobrepasar tus zonas de peligro
Hasta provocar tus gritos
Y que olvides tu apellido
sotto il sole, sotto il sole, di Riccione, di Riccione
quasi quasi mi pento e non ci penso più, e non ci penso più
faccio a schiaffi, faccio  a schiaffi, con le onde con il vento, le prendo
come se fossero te, come se fossero te, come se fossero te
dove sei, l'estate comincia adesso
ma tu vuoi correre, c'è l'apocalisse in centro
segui le luci della città, pace agli uffici e alle università
Beviamoci su che qualcosa qui non funziona, Siamo come i tori a Pamplona
Di dove siete, com’è che state? ci state bene? Estate
ciao bella, io ti conosco tu fumi cannella.
Mandala, mandala, manda a Mandela
Cinque in condotta e brucio la pagella
Hmmm, happy day!
Chiedono "Come stai-ai-ai-ai-ai?"
Chiedono "Come va?", "Come va?", "Come va?"
Ma noi non cambiamo mai no, mai no, mai. Qua è sempre il solito tran tran
Succede tutto per una ragione, E la ragione magari sei tu. Non ho niente da nascondere. E tu?
Succede tutto per una ragione
E la ragione magari sei tu
Non ho niente da promettere
Ma da scommettere con te